[Music]
okay in productive habits news like
picking her nose yes that's good you got
clear it all out yeah that's what I do
submitted by Frank from Nebraska hello
Nebraskans what is the breast 104 cow
horn isn't it the Cornhuskers uh the
brass can court my fingers like bulls
mmm well maybe not bulls okay the cows
with the bull horns what is that oh
that's gonna bison the bicycle there's
there's Buffalo did you just say chicken
with the rooster hair I'm confused
okay an entrepreneur gives advice on the
one thing you can do to boost your
productivity oh please I know what it is
brainstorm when you're taking the [ __ ]
that's good advice
Oh make it to-do list before you go to
bed every night that's what I do
really yeah I would get anxiety if I did
carry around a Productivity journal with
I make to-do lists but I also ignore
them mm-hmm
so do that too right you got to do it
you got to make one and then you do it
once I'm really big on like productivity
you got to do it and then actually
complete it and then I feels good do it
three times and you'll like it's kind of
crazy how mentally strong I am to ignore
something ignore the [ __ ] out of
something but what if your to-do list
consists of something big like finish a
movie don't put that on the life change
and then you got to look at every day
those are what my notes look like I my
to-do list make a move the world yeah
those are life goals
I know but that's my to-do list the to
do list is hard because I also need a
to-do list to get me to read my to-do
list but that's what you're doing you
put that you make that the first thing
legit elicits but then I have to read
something to get me to that to do this
so it's self defeat writer to do it yeah
so this entrepreneur says that if you
could just wake up one hour before
you're not you normally wake up already
and use that one hour to better yourself
masturbate you will be way more
that's old news I wake up at 6:30 every
morning you do why do you wake up at
6:30 for this guy's for this guy's
advice you wake up at 5:30 and then he
gives a list of things that you can do
well I work at 10:00 I work at like
10:30 in the morning I don't have to be
at work till 10:30 so getting up at 6:30
is like an early I do it a Spanish
classes are like 8 o'clock in the
morning I schedule them really early
package Paris right now you got two
Mexicans okay I think I'm a mágico hello
no yeah that's fine
okay all right you read it you ready
okay yo tengo dos Patos yep - De Aza
that's right
yo dangled by spot boss I heard it was
Patos I'm on my sixth class I try save
ducks your field audition
well it was no no no no no I was ducks
Oh duck I'm on my sixth class okay so we
won't let you suck okay let's go take
those classes at like 8 o'clock in the
morning so they're like I get myself
going I clean in the morning I usually
make lists in the morning I do it though
because I've anxiety and like people get
on my nerves and I always have people
like texting me or calling me early so I
get up before anyone has time to bring
me down and I get all my [ __ ] done and
then I go to work and then I get off
work and like I'm just chilling you know
what you can also do turn off
notifications I mean you could schedule
out when you want to respond I just like
to get up early
oh that's cool I can get everything done
in the morning and then once I get off
work like I have no worries I like that
but I can't wake up that's because you
sleep Lee yeah that's are actually doing
everything this guy suggestions suggest
things to do yeah that's a basic [ __ ]
[ __ ] it really is do you exercise
yeah when I don't know randomly either
Grillin or TIF okay I really do better
person well
when I get told me a long time you know
I started doing it in summer last year
and then when I realized that it felt
really good every morning get everything
getting everything done I was like I
have control of whether I'm happy or not
during my whole day you know what I will
say this though accomplished
accomplishing something early in the
morning does set your mood right for the
rest really does it does cuz I started
it from who knew you were talking about
doing your bed I don't do my bed but I
do the walk oh yeah yeah I accomplished
that I feel like I'm ready to go no
matter what it is I have to do that one
thing first and then I'm good to go so
it's like being able to put yourself in
a my state of doing something positive
doing that and it becomes habit feels
feels really good and I got addicted to
that sometimes I'll wake up to 6:30 and
lay in bed for the first 45 minutes but
with the eyes of course they know at the
time that your alarm goes off is still
an accomplishment to you and in like
yeah I'm like I'm like all about that
stuff you know because life is short dog
you gotta like hit a goal it's all
perception - because when I started
meeting up with Bart in the mornings to
work out I had to wake up at 6:00 right
and I'll be like oh so I only had five
hours of sleep I'm tired but then I went
to karate cap and I'm waking up at 4:00
a.m. every day and sometimes they wake
us up in the middle of the night and
then we will work out at midnight so we
only have two hours of sleep but I'm
still sharp the next day when I work out
at 4:00 a.m. so that made me go oh it's
all up here it's in and now since that
extreme was like so crazy that when I
wake up at 6:00 now this is this is cool
I can't do that yet I tried my best I
woke up today I dressed myself made
breakfast to workout with them I somehow
managed to fall asleep back on the couch
that's why I dressed up to workout - I
don't want to but if you wanted to do it
you've got something exciting your ass
would be awake like a cook fest or you
get to work under the best chef that
like you've been looking up to you'd
probably never go back when you're on
vacation and everything so fun you're
just like I just want to sleep 30
minutes all right let's go back out
vacation though I knock the [ __ ] out
when I'm on vacation I need a sleeper
ten hours I'm like this is my final time
to relax Wow get to relax I definitely
knock out pretty easy on vacation so
this guy here he is suggesting that
during that one hour that you're waking
up early every single day that hour can
be different things that you do so for
example it could be prepare for the day
or the week ahead it's like make a list
of things that you want to do and then
take advantage of it during that one
hour you can invest in independent
learning like learning a new language oh
you already do it half this [ __ ]
successful as ba don't [ __ ] [ __ ] you at
the Dukes we are yeah Harvard yeah you
want to have arts yeah I don't wonder
the start of you habit like it could be
just taking a photo tickle my balls
emailing a person to connect with or
anything am i email every week I make
to-do list at night because I found that
like I'd wake up in the morning I'd be
like someone getting up for like why do
I need to get out but if you already
have your list of the things that you
need to do you just get up you just get
right up it takes you a while but once
you get once you get into the feeling
like you literally get addicted to that
feeling of accomplishment by 10:00 a.m.
and then you're just keep doing it
my [ __ ] is play the first thing I do is
play so like I mean working out is play
because I get to like fight with my
friends and do all that if I could do
that every morning then it wires my head
to spend time on me and fun first versus
getting up and doing emails so it's like
you're yeah it's already hard enough to
wake up especially if you're
sleep-deprived and then you have to do
more [ __ ] that you don't want to do then
you don't want to wake up the next day
but if every day it's like the first
thing you do is oh [ __ ] I'm gonna go see
my friend we're gonna kick your chin you
want to do yeah and then or you you know
just mix it up do things that are I
don't like to you're what is my exact
not one hey wake up and go kick each
other public every time I watch a JK
news video after it comes out I'll fire
myself laughing really hard if some [ __ ]
david says but then in the video I'm
laughing too
same exact time it messes me up dog like
hi future Bethany we do these videos so
rapidly you don't realize how funny
these conversations are because we just
were just talking could you watch them
again a night yo that's some [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] no wonder people think we're
stupid
I feel like using like I try to compare
myself to like the extreme people over
the world and then I use that as
comparison it goes crazy ass part logic
no muhrtelle
so Tiger sleeps great night he sleeps
like a good eight hours so I'm feel
really well rested but when we first had
him and he was waking up one and then at
3 p.m. and then like like my sleep was
all [ __ ] up and then I still had to
wake up at like 5 or whatever to go
train I'm like [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] tired
all this stuff like two hours it's night
and it's been like that for like three
months and I go but what do the special
forces do they don't need a sleep
they're defending our country if the
special forces don't sleep I don't sleep
and I try to go I just do one thing at a
time I go right foot out of the bed left
foot out of the bed I just drag my feet
over and I go brush my teeth
and then I slowly go up I had the same
thing right I do that same [ __ ] but I'm
actually still dreaming as I'm saying it
cuz I'm asleep
so dreaming that I got up and I did my
[ __ ] but then I wake up and I'm MIOSHA
I'm still asleep back in high school or
when I was in school I've been getting
dressed and ready like yeah we know you
fell asleep with the protein shake and
controlling your sleep is harder than
making a million dollars yeah it is
I think so too because I made a [ __ ]
million before I controlled my sleep
that's that's the [ __ ] truth and and
still distillers Nate I battle like I
can still wake up but man the first 10
minutes I'm biting in my head I'm like
[ __ ] wiggle your [ __ ] hands wiggle
your [ __ ] toe now open your eyes
maybe 10 more minutes of sleep no
[ __ ] like that's happening every
time you know what else makes is your
sleep pretty fast
what uh having kid cuz it's like this
kids cry and you just have to get you
we're just up now like that's it just
[ __ ] that that baby could cry all day
I'm just gonna sleep it's like hard love
do you know it's crazy I think I might
have a magical skill cuz if I get up I
can still control that I'm not like my
sleep is like a crossfader
between two turntables so you know how I
bring you with season the other night
so our dog had a seizure and then so she
woke me up so I woke up and I know I'm
gonna go back to sleep so instead of
turning fully awake I'm gonna go okay
I'll I'll keep half of my body asleep
while the other half is awake so I come
downstairs on my hey babe do you need
help cuz I can fall asleep at any time
okay are you gonna go back to sleep you
are cool and then when I go in bed I can
see Jill going back to the same sleep
routine going on her phone whatever and
I'm like no I can't sleep like that
immediately because I already have it
half there once that once I wake up I'm
[ __ ]
but then I don't fully go awake though I
have half a weakness I don't get that so
I can go okay I'm not gonna wake up
Foley right now I'm just gonna do so
that when I'm like feeding Teicher I'm
like I'm just kind of I get you cuz I
would do that all the time too
especially when I take Isaac to school
I'll be like just not trying to fully
fully wake up first example you can't
sleep I mean obviously I'm driving
faithfully as soon as I get back home I
register Bank ruminated herself every
time I've been on jail with a 5b right
now that [ __ ] was wild I was like what
are you saying so I'm taking my kid to
school right so what I do is I take all
the air out the tires real quick what's
going on before I take my tattoo school
I take four sleeping pills challenge
every morning like David Goggin 15
minutes until it really hit can I chase
him with a shot I'm not a bad mom I'm
cool and I put them all up from all our
dashboards and they're all facing
towards me and I try to go over as nice
people as I can and see if they go off
just know that there are a lot of people
out there that are very successful and
they do not wake up [ __ ] early and they
do not wake up an hour
earlier than they usually do yeah
because I'm poor and I woke up at 6:00
a.m.
[Music]
[Music]